messieurs dames bonjour monsieur le
ministre bonjour et bienvenue nous
sommes très heureux de vous entendre cet
après-midi pour conclure en principe des
travaux de la commission d'enquête sur
la plateforme Tik Tok le 8 juin dernier
nous avons auditionné deux responsables
enfin deux personnes de la branche
française de l'entreprise Monsieur Eric
Garandeau et Madame Marlène masure et
sur plusieurs sujets nous n'avons pas
obtenu des réponses aussi précises que
ce que nous souhaitions ce que nous
attendions pourrez-vous nous dire si
vous concernant lors de votre rencontre
du 8 mars dernier que je me suis Éric
Anderson le Conseil Général de by dance
celui-ci s'est engagé au nom de Tik Tok
sur une feuille de route sur un
calendrier précis ou pas pour la mise en
conformité d'entreprises avec ces
diverses obligations que nous avons pu
lister au fur et à mesure de nos de nos
auditions
nous pourrions également aborder les
raisons qui ont conduit à l'interdiction
de l'utilisation de l'application sur
les téléphones des fonctionnaires par
ailleurs nous aimerions également avoir
votre appréciation sur le projet dit
Clover qui selon les responsables de
l'entreprise permettra de protéger de
manière certaine et donner personnelle
les utilisateurs européens seriez-vous
nous dire l'état d'avancement de ce
projet votre connaissance les fortes
sommes annoncées par TikTok et même
réitérer et Annonay pendant l'audition
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure pour la
mise en oeuvre de ce projet sont-elles
une réalité permettra-t-il d'obtenir des
garanties suffisantes d'étanchéité par
rapport aux intrusions et autres accès
indus bien entendu nous souhaiterions
aussi évoquer avec vous le projet de loi
visant à sécuriser réguler l'espace
numérique que le Sénat va examiner très
prochainement les règlements sur les
services et marchés numériques nous
permettront-ils d'infléchir dans
l'intérêt général les pratiques des
grandes plateformes et en particulier
celle qui nous occupent dans cette
commission d'enquête vous paraît-elle
disposer à accomplir rapidement en tout
cas dans les temps les efforts
nécessaires dans les délais requis je
pense que monsieur le rapporteur ont un
certain nombre de de questions à vous
poser nous nous allons vous entendre
dans un exposé liminaire le temps que
vous souhaiterez monsieur le ministre du
moment qu'on peut échanger ensuite je me
dois de vous rappeler que cette audition
est captée qu'elle est retransmise en
direct sur le site du Sénat et je dois
aussi vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant la commission
d'enquête et passible des peines prévues
aux articles 434 13 434 et 434 15 du
code pénal et je vous invite à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité en levant la main droite et en
disant je le jure
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole et ensuite nous
aurons un temps d'échange merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs tout
d'abord de saluer l'initiative que vous
avez prise au sein de cette commission
d'enquête les problématiques soulevées
par l'utilisation de Tik Tok une
plateforme qui s'est intriquée dans de
nombreuses facettes de notre société ne
peuvent plus être ignorés votre travail
permet d'exposer ces questions vitales
au grand jour déclenchant ainsi un débat
qui était nécessaire et urgent programme
des auditions que vous avez organisées
et plus que pertinent grâce à la
diversité des expertises sollicitées
allant des spécialistes des données au
psychologues experts sur le sujet vous
avez créé un espace d'échange et
d'apprentissage unique c'est une
démarche essentielle pour comprendre les
multiples dimensions de l'impact de
TikTok une façon plus générale des
plateformes qui jalonnent aujourd'hui la
vie quotidienne des Français je
souhaitais consacrer mon intervention à
trois sujets fondamentaux la sécurité et
la protection des données personnelles
des citoyens
les conséquences addictives et
cognitives inhérentes à l'utilisation de
TikTok et enfin une réflexion sur les
implications géopolitiques inévitables
qui accompagnent ces questions tout
d'abord la protection et la sécurité des
données TikTok premier succès
technologique indéniable à conquis la
planète en un temps record avec 1,7
milliards de téléchargements depuis sa
création en 2020 la plateforme a
recueilli une quantité impressionnante
de données trois ans plus tard nous
devons nous interroger ce succès est-il
mérité ou repose-t-il sur un abus est-il
loyal et surtout est-il en accord avec
nos valeurs allaient un des données
personnelles se révélant comme levier
économique la protection de celle-ci
devient une question de souveraineté un
sujet dont nous avons fait une priorité
avec Bruno Le Maire les données
dépassent les frontières des entreprises
et redessine la géopolitique mondiale
l'Europe a su forgé un premier bouclier
face à cette menace le rgpd
ce texte est plus qu'un simple règlement
c'est une affirmation des valeurs
européennes il place l'individu au cœur
de ses préoccupations et réaffirme son
droit inaliénable à la protection de ces
données personnelles le rgpd est un
standard qui n'est pas encore pleinement
respecté par TikTok ce qui appelle à une
réponse ferme la CNIL a déjà frappé en
fonctionnant Tik Tok en décembre dernier
avec une amende de 5 millions d'euros et
ce signal fort résonne comme un
avertissement le respect du modèle
européen de protection des données n'est
pas une faveur que nous demandons c'est
une exigence que nous posons cette
sanction alimente le faisceau d'indices
qui nous interroge sur la compatibilité
entre les lois étrangères et nos
législations ce constat mérite toute
notre attention et notre vigilance nous
avons exhorté Tik Tok à se conformer
assez normes indiscutables des promesses
ont été faites des engagements ont été
pris via des gages de la volonté de la
plateforme d'assurer une protection
durable des données de nos concitoyens
en réalisant les investissements
nécessaires en ce sens notamment dans
des centres de données européens le
projet dénommé Clover a été annoncé par
Tik Tok et il est en concrétisation en
ce moment sur ce point je serai
intransigeant TikTok doit traiter toutes
les données des Européens en Europe avec
des structures qui garantissent
l'impossibilité technique de les envoyer
en dehors du continent c'est tout
simplement l'esprit et la lettre du rgpd
ensuite concernant les travers de
l'algorithme de Tik Tok c'est le
deuxième point que je souhaitais
développer devant vous au centre du
modèle économique de Tik Tok avec son
design racoleur et intuitif retrouvent
l'individu et bien souvent des jeunes
publics
Tik Tok ce titan de l'économie de la
tension leur ses utilisateurs dans un
océan infini de contenu conçu pour
engloutir leur temps et leur
concentration c'est le résultat d'une
stratégie délibérée intégrée dans la
conception même de l'application
les algorithmes sont des outils
puissants qui apprennent de nos
préférences et de nos comportements pour
nous proposer un flux personnalisé de
contenu mais ne soyons pas naïfs
l'algorithme de Tik Tok n'est pas neutre
il favorise certaines vidéos certains
messages certains comportements en
fonction d'objectifs commerciaux plutôt
que d'intérêts sociaux ou éducatifs
plusieurs des personnes que vous avez
auditionnées l'ont démontré Tik Tok
exploite habilement des mécanismes de
récompense et de renforcement cognitif
pour créer un lien quasi compulsif avec
ses utilisateurs Tik Tok a choisi de
développer un produit fondamentalement
addictif en offrant aux utilisateurs ce
qu'ils désirent voir dans une logique
d'utilisation du scrolling qui ne
s'arrête jamais un modèle qui a depuis
été copié par d'autres plateformes et
notamment Instagram ou Youtube
l'effet est particulièrement prononcé
chez les plus jeunes dans les esprits en
développement sont particulièrement
sensibles à ces stimuli plusieurs études
et démonstrations vous ont été
présentées durant les précédentes
auditions qui en viennent toutes à la
conclusion que ce type de réseau social
de vidéos courtes et fondées sur
l'économie de l'attention engendre des
conséquences graves sur la santé
physique et mentale des jeunes la
promesse initiale de Tik Tok et je le
souligne était de s'abstraire
d'algorithmes fondés sur le graphe
social pour aller vers une logique
d'exploration de nouveaux contenus au
delà des contenus poussés par le grave
social c'est à dire par les
les comptes des utilisateurs avec
lesquels on est lié dans les faits
l'utilisateur est conduit vers un
enfermement
par un mécanisme de sursollicitation des
des mécanismes de récompense du cerveau
et une utilisation agressive de
l'intelligence artificielle face à cela
le règlement européen sur les services
numériques adopter sous président
françaises de l'Union européenne sous
l'impulsion du Président de la
République et l'outil
adéquatik Tok a été désigné comme une
très grande plateforme par la Commission
européenne dans le cadre de ce règlement
et devra à ce titre rendre des comptes
dès le 25 août prochain date de l'entrée
en vigueur de ce règlement Tik Tok devra
notamment respecter l'interdiction de la
publicité ciblée pour les mineurs et
mettre en oeuvre des mesures strictes
pour lutter contre les contenus
illicites en effectuant annuellement des
audits indépendants de réduction des
risques et en analysant l'ensemble des
risques systématiques des risques
systémiques pardon que cette plateforme
fait peser sur ses utilisateurs sur leur
bien-être et leur santé mentale physique
dans le chaos Tik Tok ne respecterait
pas ces obligations nouvelles des
sanctions seront prononcées allant
jusqu'à 6% de son chiffre d'affaires
soit en vilion environ 560 millions
d'euros et pouvant aller jusqu'à une
interdiction d'opérer en Europe dès
l'entrée en vigueur du Règlement sur les
services numériques la Commission
européenne avec l'appui de l'arcom en
France pourra ainsi commencer les
perquisitions les interrogatoires les
collectes de données massives et à
mobiliser le monde de la recherche pour
accroître notre compréhension du
fonctionnement des plateformes à titre
d'exemple en France le pôle d'expertise
de la régulation numérique le pérenne a
pour projet d'effectuer des
expérimentations sur Tik Tok en matière
d'instrumentation d'applications mobiles
et de type algorithmique sur la
recommandation de vidéos de Tik Tok je
ne peux que réaffirmer ici l'importance
de donner les moyens à nos chercheurs
d'explorer d'auditer les grands
algorithmes de notre quotidien dans des
conditions de transparence accrue
il est en effet grand temps de repenser
le rôle et la responsabilité des
plateformes numériques dans notre
société le projet de loi visant à
sécuriser réguler l'espace numérique qui
sera examiné tout prochainement au Sénat
incarnera à ce titre avec force
l'ambition du Règlement sur les services
numériques avec des mesures
additionnelles ambitieuses pour notre
pays enfin je tiens à souligner ici ce
qui peut apparaître comme un détail mais
qui a son importance pour comprendre les
enjeux liés à l'algorithme de Tik Tok en
effet en Chine Tik Tok a un nom et un
algorithme différent l'application se
nomme douille in et propose des contenus
substantiellement différents de plus à
l'intérieur de ces frontières la Chine
limite la durée d'utilisation et
contrôle étroitement le contenu elle
censure et jette un voile sur des sujets
que nous ne pouvons pas ignorer la
conclusion est simple la Chine ne tolère
pas sur son propre sol ce qu'elle permet
à l'étranger à travers une entreprise
quel contrôle cette contradiction met en
relief l'ambition chinoise d'éduquer ses
élites tout en établissement des
restrictions sur un certain modèle
d'engagement numérique pour sa
population générale
cette situation binaire incite à une
réflexion plus profonde sur les impacts
et les défis posés par des plateformes
telles que Tik Tok face à de tels
constats je ne peux éluder l'aspect
hautement géopolitique des questions
dont nous traitons aujourd'hui c'est le
troisième sujet que je voulais aborder
dans ce propos liminaire
car le monde numérique d'aujourd'hui
n'est pas exempt de frontière bien au
contraire la géographie de l'information
c'est complexifiée la question de la
provenance des services numériques que
nous utilisons devient une préoccupation
majeure Tic-Toc n'est pas simplement une
application de partage de vidéo c'est
également un acteur de l'économie
numériquement mondiale avec un
rattachement territorial à ne pas
oublier un fait est incontestable
Tic-Toc symbolise le premier cas de la
tech grand public qui réussit aussi bien
voir mieux que les Américains sur leur
propre terrain ceci reflète l'ambition
technologique de la Chine et l'activisme
dont elle a fait montre ces dernières
années ces applications mondialement
répandues accèdent à un grand nombre des
données des téléphones sur lesquels
elles opèrent ou des équipements plus
généralement pour autant dans le cadre
du rgpd que je citais précédemment
l'Union européenne n'a pas signé
d'accord d'adéquation avec la Chine il
nous faut donc nous doter de mesures et
d'outils pour prévenir tout détournement
de l'application ou un mes usages de ces
succès technologiques à des fins
d'exploitation des données mais aussi de
rivalité ou d'ingérence c'est dans ce
sens que la Commission européenne et le
gouvernement français ont pris des
mesures concrètes consistant à
l'interdiction d'installer certaines
applications dont Tik Tok sur les
appareils officiels notre approche en
matière de sécurité numérique ne se base
pas sur l'identification d'amis ou
d'ennemis que ce soit en termes de pays
ou d'entreprise nous nous focalisons
exclusivement sur la sécurisation la
sécurisation de nos systèmes et la
protection de nos utilisateurs et des
données qui sont associées dans ce
contexte toutes nos décisions sont
motivées par des impératifs de sécurité
et non par des préférences ou des
animosités c'est d'ailleurs en ce sens
que nous avons pris la décision
d'interdire l'installation des
applications réacréatives dont Tik Tok
sur les téléphones des fonctionnaires et
est important de préciser qu'il ne
s'agit pas seulement de Tik Tok les
médias simplifient souvent à outrance
les décisions que nous prenons mais en
réalité l'interdiction concerne tous les
applis toutes les applications à usage
non professionnel sur les appareils
professionnels ce n'est pas une mesure
spécifique à Tik Tok mais une politique
générale visant à garantir la sécurité
de nos systèmes d'information la logique
est simple plus nous autorisons
d'application non contrôlée sur nos
appareils professionnels plus nous
augmentons notre surface d'exposition au
cyberattaque cette mesure n'est pas une
réaction à TikTok en tant que tel mais
une réponse à une menace plus globale et
plus persistante celle de la
cybersécurité et de la protection des
données de nos administrations dans un
monde de plus en plus connecté mais ici
encore le Règlement sur les services
numériques apportera des garanties pour
parents toute tentative d'ingérence ou
de manipulation de l'information au
travers d'algorithmes personnalisé le
règlement va en effet obliger les
grandes plateformes dont Tik Tok à faire
preuve de plus de transparence et de
responsabilité en matière de lutte
contre la désinformation on les
contraignant à une plus grande
transparence quant à la modération de
leur contenu notamment via la
publication de rapports annuels
déroulant leur pratique de modération et
je le répète si c'est garanti ne sont
pas respectées TikTok ne pourra plus
opérer sur le territoire de l'Union
européenne
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
ne serai pas plus long pour laisser
place à nos questions
le sujet de Tik Tok n'est pas seulement
celui d'un réseau social populaire et
intrigant Tik Tok à lui seul illustre
les défis économiques sociétaux et
politiques auxquelles nous devons
répondre collectivement en ce sens je
suivrai la ligne directrice qui oriente
mon action depuis ma prise de fonction
et qui fera écho dans cette institution
sécurisée et protéger les citoyens dans
l'espace numérique coûte que coûte merci
pour votre attention
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président et bienvenue
au Sénat monsieur le ministre merci
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
comme le disait tout à l'heure le
Président nous sommes en train de
terminer les auditions et nous terminons
en beauté si je peux dire
mais toutes ces auditions et notamment
notre visite à la Commission européenne
nous ont par bien des aspects préoccupés
c'est d'ailleurs le c'était d'ailleurs
le cas au départ dans la volonté de
cette création de la commission
d'enquête
le premier point que je voudrais évoquer
c'est celui que vous avez ok également
en premier le transfert massif de
données par TikTok en Chine et désormais
une certitude
les messages interceptés par buzzfuie
dans novembre le prouve les dirigeants
de bail d'Inde sont été obligés de le
reconnaître en disant comme d'habitude
que c'était une erreur que les employés
ont été licenciés et que ça ne se
reproduira pas etc etc on a l'habitude
du discours des plateformes
or les messages interceptés sont clairs
je fais une citation parmi d'autres d'un
responsable de Tik Tok sur ses mails
tout se voit à Pékin
il s'agit donc d'un transfert de données
massif et permanent
les dirigeants de TikTok ont par
ailleurs avoué que des entreprises
chinoises participaient à la gestion de
la plateforme après l'avoir nié pendant
des années
la plateforme notamment de son
algorithme
c'est sans doute en raison de ses
révélations que la que l'Union
européenne et aussi trois mois
d'interdire le chargement de
l'application sur les téléphones de ses
fonctionnaires cette décision suivie par
la plupart des pays européens posent
plusieurs questions
d'abord l'Union européenne n'a pas donné
les raisons précises de ces décisions
même pressé par des journalistes qui
assistaient à la déclaration cette
décision
de la même façon
la France
c'est un petit peu singularisé pas de la
même façon mais par ailleurs la France
est quand même d'habitude un petit peu
singularisé en ajoutant plusieurs
applications à Tik Tok
la seule qui avait été épinglé par les
autres pays
en ajoutant Netflix notamment et
d'autres elle a fait excusez-moi le
ministre sourire
pas mal de monde
je suis certain d'ailleurs que la
décision française n'a pas été prises en
ce qui concerne Netflix par votre
ministère parce que je ne pense pas que
vous auriez fait une toile de cette
nature personne ne montera de l'idée que
le Quai d'Orsay tremblait une fois de
plus de déclencher le courroux de
cuisine à quelques jours du voyage en
Chine du président de la République
bref personne n'est expliqué la raison
de cette décision les raisons de cette
décision à l'exception du Premier
ministre belge Alexander de Crau qui n'a
pas eu peur de mettre les pieds dans le
plat je le cite TikTok est une
entreprise chinoise qui est obligée de
coopérer avec des services de
renseignement chinois c'est la réalité
interdire son utilisation sur les
appareils de service fédéraux relève du
bon sens cette décision est prise avec
l'appui de la Sûreté de l'État et le
Centre pour la cybersécurité belge
ma première question est simple monsieur
le ministre est-ce que le Premier
ministre belge dit la vérité et pourquoi
est-ce que tout le monde a l'air de
trembler comme une feuille à l'idée d'en
dire autant est-ce que vous confirmez la
déclaration du Premier ministre belge ou
sinon quelle est l'explication du
gouvernement français si elle est
différente
et enfin pouvez-vous nous indiquer les
dangers que vous êtes flics au téléphone
des fonctionnaires de l'État français
merci monsieur le rapporteur
souhaitez-vous monsieur le Président
peut-être que je rentre un peu plus en
détail dans les questions que vous avez
posées avant de répondre à la question
de monsieur le rapporteur
sur la question de des échanges que nous
avons pu avoir avec les représentants de
Tik Tok
j'ai rencontré pour ma part shujitsu le
le CO le CEO le PDG de Tik Tok en
janvier afin d'échanger sur la
modération des contenus la protection
des des mineurs et le DSA DMA
aussi et par la suite j'ai convoqué Eric
Andersen vice-président et directeur
juridique de by dance le 10 mai 2023
pour passer en revue certains
engagements de de Tik Tok nous avons
abordé plusieurs questions importantes
lors de cette rencontre notamment le
projet Clover le projet Texas équivalent
du projet Clover si l'on peut dire aux
États-Unis ainsi que le DSA ldma nous
avons également discuté de la protection
des mineurs une question qui reste une
priorité majeure pour nous je peux vous
confirmer que lors de cette rencontre
Monsieur Anderson a manifesté une
volonté de coopération claire et c'est
engagé à travailler étroitement avec
notre ministère sur ces questions
notamment Tik Tok a formu des
engagements concrets pour la protection
des données en Europe avec la mise en
place du projet Clover par ailleurs le
cabinet mon cabinet est également en
contact régulier avec Eric Garandeau qui
a d'ailleurs été auditionné par votre
commission d'enquête en ce qui concerne
la protection des mineurs tik Tok a
récemment pris des mesures concrètes en
s'engageant aux côtés de l'association
et en France pour la mise en place du
numéro d'appel 30 18 sur l'application
cette initiative montre une volonté de
la part de Tik Tok d'améliorer la
sécurité des plus jeunes utilisateurs
sur leur plateforme nous continuerons à
maintenir des discussions exigeantes
avec Tik Tok afin de nous assurer que
toutes nos règles toutes nos valeurs
soient respectées
j'en viens maintenant
à la question que que vous me posiez
monsieur le Président et sur laquelle
monsieur le rapporteur a ajouté une
question qui est celle de l'interdiction
par la Commission européenne de Tik Tok
sur les appareils fournis à ses
fonctionnaires la décision de la
Commission européenne en réalité des
institutions européennes d'interdire Tik
Tok soulignent le sérieux des
préoccupations liées à la sécurité des
données et à la protection de la vie
privée que suscite les plateformes
numériques en particulier celles qui ont
leur siège social en dehors de l'Union
Européenne ça met en évidence
l'importance cruciale de garantir que
les entreprises respectent les normes
élevées de protection des données
personnelles que nous avons en Europe il
s'agit également d'un rappel que nous en
tant que dirigeant public avant la
responsabilité de prendre des mesures
pour protéger la confidentialité des
communications et des données de nos
agents nous devons également nous
assurer que nous utilisons des
plateformes qui sont conformes à nos
principes en matière de respect de la
vie privée de sécurité des données et
des tics numériques cependant tout en
respectant les préoccupations de la
Commission européenne nous devons aussi
reconnaître que Tik Tok et d'autres
plateformes de médias sociaux sont des
outils de communication et d'expression
populaire en particulier parmi les plus
jeunes il est donc crucial de trouver un
équilibre entre la garantie de la
sécurité de nos fonctionnaires et le
respect du droit des individus à
utiliser les plateformes numériques de
leur choix
pour ce qui concerne la décision de la
France le choix qui a été retenu est
effectivement d'interdire l'installation
sur les appareils fournis par l'état des
applications récréatives au premier rang
desquelles Tik Tok mais d'autres mais
également il est important de noter que
les décisions de restriction ou
d'interdiction d'applications
spécifiques sur les appareils
professionnels sont souvent le résultat
d'une évaluation complexe des risques en
matière de cybersécurité de protection
des données chaque plateforme présente
un ensemble unique de risques et
davantage potentiels qui doivent être
évalués individuellement TikTok en
particulier a fait l'objet de
préoccupation mondiale contre sa gestion
des données des utilisateurs et de
possibilités avec le gouvernement
chinois est également largement reconnu
comme une plateforme récréative ce qui
ne peut pas être approprié pour un usage
professionnel
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
applications
récréatives sollicitant de la part de
leurs utilisateurs des masses
considérables de données au travers de
l'accès qu'il requiert au moment de
l'inscription à au contact au document
stockés sur ces appareils que nous avons
pris la décision de les interdire sur
les appareils professionnels sauf
exception quant à la question de Netflix
que monsieur le rapporteur évoqué je ne
saurais pas vous dire exactement ce que
sont les données qui sont collectées par
Netflix au moment de l'inscription
mais je si comme pour d'autres
applications récréatives Netflix
requiert l'accès à un certain nombre de
données contenues sur le sur le
smartphone des agents publics il nous il
apparaît indispensable dans l'interdire
sauf exception l'installation pour
éviter d'augmenter la surface d'attaque
à l'encontre de nos administrations
j'en viens maintenant à quelques détails
qui mettaient demandées sur le projet
Clover TikTok souhaiterait en Europe le
modèle mis en place aux États-Unis
avec Oracle l'entreprise américaine
héberge depuis l'été 2022 les données
des utilisateurs de Tik Tok dans le pays
et vous dites ces algorithmes dans ce
cas Tik Tok a annoncé le 8 mars 2023 son
projet Clover qui permet en principe une
réduction de l'accès aux données des
Européens sur la base de leurs approches
de leur approches aux États-Unis un
contrôle externe de l'accès aux données
le processus de contrôle d'accès aux
données est supervisé et vérifiée par un
partenaire européen tiers un stockage en
local des données via l'ouverture de 3
centres de données européen en
colocation et exploitation par des
fournisseurs de services tiers de
confiance la migration se poursuivra
jusqu'en 2024 une fois opérationnelle
c'est 300 de données et
pour un investissement annuel de 1,2
milliards d'euros à cet égard la France
est fermement résolue à assurer que les
engagements pris par Tik Tok dans le
cadre de son projet Clover respecte ses
principes fondamentaux en ce qui
concerne ce projet nous attendons de Tik
Tok une transparence exemplaire et une
moyenne mise en oeuvre rapide et
efficace nous exigeons un contrôle
robuste de la restriction de l'accès des
employés aux données des utilisateurs
qui offrent une garantie maximale
d'indépendance et implique un contrôle
public nous tenons à ce que ce projet
soit concrétisé rapidement pour répondre
aux préoccupations de nos concitoyens et
assurer leur sécurité en ligne de plus
nous resterons vigilants à ce que Tik
Tok respecte pleinement le cadre
européen de protection de la vie privée
pour protéger les droits et les intérêts
de nos concitoyens
merci beaucoup monsieur Miss préciser ma
deuxième question vous y avez répondu
la deuxième partie de ma question que
j'avais encore partie mais
vous avez dit que Netflix c'est le cas
aussi d'Instagram et de snapchat je
crois qu'ils ont été interdits en même
temps que Tik Tok sur les téléphones des
fonctionnaires français
vous l'avez justifié ou non
de la collecte de données importante sur
les téléphones mais Google et Facebook
en demande largement autant sinon
beaucoup plus que c'est que Netflix ou
Instagram et snapchat et ils ne sont pas
partis de la liste des applications
interdites de téléchargement est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer pourquoi
merci monsieur le
rapporteur
il y a entre des services comme
WhatsApp par exemple et les applications
récréatives que que vous citez une
différence parfois en termes d'accès
au contenu stocké sur les équipements je
vous le disais
la raison principale qui a
guidé la décision d'interdire ces
applications répliques récré-créatives
sur les téléphones des agents publics
c'est d'éviter d'augmenter la surface
d'attaque d'autre part WhatsApp est
largement utilisé à des fins de
communication professionnelles et
privées il a mis en œuvre le chiffrement
de bout en bout pour protéger la
Confédération des communications
cependant cela ne signifie pas que
WhatsApp est exemple préoccupation en
matière de cybersécurité et de
protection des données il existe des
applications et notamment des
applications ou des services de
messagerie
français et souverain qui garantissent
un niveau plus élevé de sécurité je
voudrais en particulier citer le cas
dolvide
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre une
deuxième question si la raison de
l'interdiction de Tik Tok au
fonctionnaires français repose sur le
transfert de données en Chine et par
conséquent potentiellement aux parties
communistes chinois c'est ce que vous
expliquez je dis bien potentiellement
c'est ce que vous avez dit il est bien
évident qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
possèdent des données tout aussi
confidentielles que celles des
fonctionnaires de l'État français le
personnel des entreprises de sécurité
nationale qui ne sont pas qui sont
privés
pour certaines entreprises commerciales
avec le problème du secret commercial
notamment et beaucoup d'autres alors je
voulais vous demander quelque chose
est-il prévu au niveau européen comme au
niveau français pour rendre impossible
ces transfert de données
voilà dans tous les cas où elle est
problématique est-ce qu'il y a un
recensement qui est actuellement en
train d'être fait est-ce qu'il y a des
directives je ne parle pas
d'interdiction je comprends que pour
l'État il est plus facile et normal
d'atteindre assez fonctionnaires qu'elle
est société
mais c'est tout de même un problème qui
se pose parce que ces sociétés sont
souvent autant si non plus
potentiellement des cibles que celle de
certains fonctionnaires d'État
merci monsieur le rapporteur s'agissant
des données personnelles le cadre dont
nous disposons et celui du rgpd et c'est
sur le fondement de ce cadre que nous
exigeons de la part de Tik Tok un
traitement en Europe des données des
Européens nous souhaitons
que le projet Clover puisse avancer
comme Tik Tok SCI est engagé et qu'enfin
les données des Européens puissent être
traités par Tik Tok dans un esprit enfin
dans l'esprit en suivant l'esprit et la
lettre du rgpd et
nous y veillerons et les cnils
européennes y vailleront s'agissant
maintenant des données sensibles celles
que détiennent nos administrations ou
certaines de nos entreprises la France
c'est de tes d'une doctrine
qu'on appelle la doctrine du cloud de
confiance en érigeant une certification
délivrée par l'ansy
intitulé secmin cloud qui garantit que
l'hébergement de qu'une solution
d'hébergement
notamment une solution d'info nuagique
garantit la protection de ces données
contre divers attaques
mais aussi contre l'extraterritorialité
des des lois extra-européennes
certification s'applique
aux administrations lorsqu'elles font
migrer leur donner vers le Cloud mais
au mois de septembre dernier le 12
septembre dernier avec Bruno Le Maire
nous avons
fortement encouragé les entreprises
françaises de des secteurs critiques à
considérer très sérieusement pour la
migration de leur donner vers un
hébergement en nuage de considérer des
offres certifiées secs sont d'ailleurs
de nature diverses et commencent à
apparaître et être mis sur le marché au
niveau européen une réflexion est en
cours pour l'établissement d'un schéma
de certification
volontaire qui servira de référence pour
les schémas de certification retenus par
les États membres nous plaidons depuis
le début de cette discussion pour que ce
schéma de certification
qui s'intitule e UCS intègre dans son
niveau de sécurité le plus élevé la
protection des données non personnelles
notamment à l'extraterritorialité des
législations
extra-européenne c'est une discussion
qui n'a pas encore abouti qui suppose de
notre part un véritable travail de
conviction puisque sur ces sujets la
protection des données non personnelles
sensibles en particulier c'est bien la
France qui est en avance de phase et
dans un effort soutenu de conviction des
États membres des autres États membres
de l'Union européenne une fois ce schéma
de certification établi nous aurons donc
le RGP avec le rgpd pour les données
personnelles avec le schéma eucs pour
les données personnelles un arsenal de
protection de de nos données et de notre
patrimoine immatériel
merci beaucoup
pardon mais pour relancer la question de
monsieur le Président n'est pas prévu de
lister les entreprises comme on liste
les opérateurs d'importance vitale par
exemple auquel on contraindrait à ne pas
utiliser
ce type d'application un certain niveau
de
responsabilité parce que s'il rentre
plus par les fonctionnaires
enfin il les personnes malveillantes de
manière générale peuvent rentrer par
d'autres biais est-ce qu'on réhausse
notre niveau de sécurité est-ce qu'on en
a pas les moyens juridiques ou est-ce
que ce n'est pas le souhait du
gouvernement
alors en matière de
de
sécurité cyber
ce qui se profile à l'horizon c'est
la
mise en application d'une directive la
directive Nice 2 qui va être transposé
en droit français dans les mois qui
viennent et qui va élargir en réalité
multipliée par 10 le nombre des
entreprises qui sont assujetties à un
certain nombre d'obligations en matière
de cyberdéfense et de cybersécurité
jusqu'à présent ces obligations
concernées les opérateurs d'importance
vitale les opérateurs de service
essentiels c'est-à-dire plusieurs
centaines avec la transposition de Nice
2 ce seront plusieurs milliers
d'entreprises qui seront assez
obligations et qu'on va d'ailleurs
essayer d'accompagner dans cette
démarche là ensuite en ce qui concerne
les les réquisitions
une part des États extra-européens de
données stockées dans des solutions
d'hébergement dont les fournisseurs sont
issus de ces de ces états ce que nous
avons dit le 12 septembre dernier avec
Bruno Le Maire c'est que la la la
doctrine du cloud de confiance
s'imposerait aux administrations mais
qu'il y avait à ce stade une forte
incitation
au fait aux entreprises des secteurs
critiques ou disposant de données
sensibles de s'orienter vers ces
solutions sans quoi à terme des mesures
de coercition ne pouvaient pas être
écarté
vous avez cité tout à l'heure monsieur
Andersen qui vous a assuré de sa volonté
de Total coopération
il y a une chose qui nous a paru assez
intéressante voir ironique lors de
toutes nos auditions c'est que chaque
fois qu'on écoute les dirigeants de Tik
Tok le mot qui revient le plus souvent
dans leur bouche c'est celui de
transparence il le brandit son
permanence et lorsque nous avons écouté
tous les tous les autres les services de
l'État les agences les régulateurs le
mot qui revient les journalistes qui ont
fait des enquêtes le mot qui revient le
plus souvent c'est celui d'opacité donc
là dedans il y a quelqu'un qui ne dit
pas obligatoirement la vérité
je voulais vous demander votre opinion
et l'opinion du gouvernement français
vous avez parlé de Bruno Le Maire tout à
l'heure
de Bercy peut-être vous la connaissez
puisque vous avez parlé avec lui sur
[Musique]
la
sur la transparence
à partir du moment où la localisation du
siège de Tik Tok et de bidens est aux
îles Caïmans
et sur l'impossibilité de connaître les
droits de vote des actionnaires dont
certains sont chinois et par conséquent
de savoir qui décide indépendamment des
problèmes fiscaux
sur lesquels le maire est sans doute
plus intéressé que vous mais indépendant
des problèmes fiscaux l'impossibilité de
savoir qui dessine si ce sont les fonds
d'investissement occidentaux qui sont là
pour faire de l'argent uniquement ou si
ce sont des personnes que
l'extra-territorialité des lois
chinoises obligent à obéir une fine
parce qu'elle s'est désormais comme le
Cloud acte américain mais beaucoup plus
violent l'extraterritorialité du droit
chinois qui oblige les Chinois à en
référé au service de renseignement c'est
la moindre demande et qu'il désormais
les oblige même lorsqu'ils sont à
l'étranger donc où est-ce que ce sont
ces personnes qui sont je dirais
victimes ou en tout cas sujettes à
l'extraitériorité de la chinoise dont le
principal qui est un des principaux
actionnaires de
qui est monsieur John gaming pour 26% à
titre personnel je crois a été obligé en
début de l'année 2023 a été obligé comme
Jack ma comme d'autres par le
gouvernement chinois de céder les 99% du
capital de Douai en Chine à une société
dans laquelle siège les représentants du
Parti communiste chinois
voilà je voulais vous demander votre
opinion et l'opinion du gouvernement là
dessus est-ce que ça paraît pas un petit
peu
un contraste entre la proclamation de
transparence et la réalité de l'opacité
et après tout est-ce que le gouvernement
français ne peut-il demander à Tik Tok
puisque il vous disent qu'ils sont
transparents nous nous avons demandé
nous n'avons pas eu la réponse aux
dirigeants français de Tik Tok est-ce
que le gouvernement français c'est un
souhait éventuellement si ça n'est pas
fait aujourd'hui et susceptible pas où
exactement les forçant mais dans une
démonstration de la volonté transparence
de demander aux dirigeants de Tik Tok
français quelle est la composition de la
Valle
que représente by dance au caïman
[Musique]
la répartition du capital et surtout
surtout la répartition des droits de
vote
merci monsieur le rapporteur en termes
d'organisation juridique TikTok et les
autres entités de Biden sont
complètement séparées détient
intégralement TikTok limited qui a son
tour possède des filiales dans
différents territoires pour l'Europe
l'entité mère et TikTok
UK dont Tik Tok SAS France est une
filiale par ailleurs Tik Tok Irlande et
l'entité en charge des questions
relatives au rgpd et au DSA un site
TikTok opère selon une chaîne juridique
définie et soumise à un endroit qui
n'est pas chinois le lien avec la Chine
est établi à travers doine qui est une
autre filiale de binance
sur la question de la transparence il y
a la transparence du service et la
transparence de l'actionnariat je vais
d'abord dire un mot sur la transparence
du service en rappelant que le règlement
sur les services numériques qui impose
un certain nombre d'obligations à partir
du 25 août prochain auquel Tik Tok comme
les 16 autres acteurs concernés va
devoir se plier
introduit des obligations de
transparence d'audit externe des
algorithmes et de partage des données
aux chercheurs cela fait partie des
obligations qui sont sanctionnées par
les amendes que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure qui peuvent aller jusqu'à 6% du
chiffre d'affaires mondial voire même
l'interdiction d'exercer dans l'Union
européenne et quand
au rgpd qui reste en vigueur il interdit
le traitement des données à l'extérieur
de l'Union européenne lorsque le pays
conc pas signé avec l'Europe un accord
d'adéquation ces accords d'adéquation
nous en avons signé avec le Royaume-Uni
avec le Japon avec la Corée avec la
Nouvelle-Zélande nous n'en n'avons pas
avec la Chine nous n'en avons pas encore
d'ailleurs signé avec les États-Unis à
quoi servent ces
décisions d'adéquation ces accords
d'adéquation et bien à garantir à
l'Europe et à ses citoyens que le pays
vers lequel leur donner son transférées
respectent un certain nombre de
principes peut-être pas exactement les
mêmes que ceux qui figurent dans le
texte du rgpd mais qui
qui sont adéquat
comme l'indique le nom de ces accords ou
qui sont équivalents aux mesures de
protection de recours également prévu
par le rgpd
sur le fonctionnement de
de la plateforme sur le service Tik Tok
en principe avec le DSA et le rgpd à
condition bien sûr que
c'est politique soit ou c'est pardon ces
règlements soient correctement exécutés
par les autorités qui en ont la charge
c'est notamment la Commission européenne
pour le DSA nous disposons d'éléments de
protection satisfaisant quand
à la transparence sur la structure
actionnariale et la variable variable
interest entity que vous évoquez
la répartition du capital la répartition
des droits de vote je n'ai pas la
réponse à cette question mais je vous
propose effectivement dans référer à
Bruno Le Maire et d'envisager avec lui
les moyens d'obtenir cette information
merci monsieur le ministre je suis
désolé je vais insister sur cette
question parce que pour nous il est
important
d'abord vous nous dites que il n'y a pas
de lien avec la Chine puisque le seul
lien avec la Chine c'est douilline c'est
évidemment un lien avec la Chine puisque
c'est une société chinoise et qui
s'implique purement
citoyen chinois en Chine
mais ce n'est pas ça le lien justement
le lien a été juridiquement cassé que
vous l'avez expliqué tout à l'heure au
début
en créant en créant des filiales d'un
côté occidental et de l'autre côté
chinoise et sous l'ombrelle de weidens
caïman donc entre les sociétés chinoise
il y a pas de lien direct Sidney qu'il
est bien évident qu'il y a un lien par
la maison mère qui est Bayonne ce caïman
mais ce que je disais c'est que
le lien avec la Chine ça n'est pas par
douille c'est par l'extraterritorialité
du droit chinois qui impose à Monsieur
changing komado d'obéir à la cime comme
il a été obligé de le faire en cédant
99% de ses parts dans dans
bandouline à Shanghai sinon il lui
serait vous imaginez ce start-up comme
Jack ma comme Zuckerberg et tout qui a
38 ans d'un seul coup sans avoir jamais
prévenu cette c'est les 99% du capital
de Douai qui est appelé avant TikTok
c'est d'un seul coup
et
à une société créée 20 jours auparavant
avec une société dans les deux parts
sont détenus par deux individus à 50%
totalement inconnus vous avez déjà vu
des startups dans les dirigeants ne sont
pas
ou des entreprises de la tech dans les
dirigeants sont inconnus sur les réseaux
sociaux etc et qui sont tous les deux
issus de
chanmen d'ailleurs c'est le nom commence
par tiennes
qui est précisément quelle coïncidence
la ville dont un monsieur Jinping était
le maire adjoint il y a quelques années
avant de commencer son ascension
politique
et par conséquent et de deux inconnus
dont l'un on a quand même réussi à
savoir qu'il était membre du Parti
communiste chinois mais qui sont
exactement
issus de la même région que monsieur
Guillaume
voilà donc ma question c'est c'est celle
là cette ce lien il est pas il est pas
juridique il est pas pardonné évidemment
qu'il n'est pas juridique puisque
ils essaient désespérément de montrer
qu'il y a pas de lien le lien il est à
travers
Biden's caïmans ou monsieur Gianni
principal actionnaire est obligé comme
il a été obligé non seulement de céder
son capital mais de faire une
autocritique à la MAO
le président à laquelle je vous renvoie
si vous le souhaitez le voir on se
croirait en 19 au moment du grand bon en
avant de céder toutes séparés de faire
un petit peu auparavant une autocritique
totale qui est de fermée un certain
nombre des applications de la société
dont il
possédait
voilà pourquoi je vous pose la question
des îles caï membres là pourquoi je
voulais poser la question de cette
transparence voilà pourquoi je vous pose
la question de cette opacité
[Musique]
moi je pense que le gouvernement
français devrait s'occuper de ça et au
minimum
et le plus vite possible parce que on
peut pas plaider la transparence alors
que cette en un mail en une heure
monsieur Garandeau ou monsieur Andersen
ou n'importe qui à Tico France peut
s'ils veulent bien être transparents
vous donnez avec juste un mail ou un sms
au caïman si c'est tellement transparent
que ça le la composition du capital et
la composition des droits de vote de
bindown skymore et s'ils ne veulent pas
par tous les moyens s'il refuse par tous
les moyens de la de la donnée
c'est je pense que c'est l'équivalent
d'une réponse de la pire réponse la
candisée un acte manqué est un discours
réussi là on est vraiment en plein
dans la cible
merci monsieur le rapporteur je le redis
c'est bien volontiers que avec Bruno Le
Maire nous relèverons cette question sur
la variable intestinity les pourcentages
de droits de vote les pourcentages de
capital
mais il me paraît important de rappeler
que au-delà de cette transparence
nécessaire sur le fonctionnement et la
répartition du pouvoir chez Tik Tok
vous vous avez eu raison de dire qu'il
s'agit avant tout d'une entreprise
chinoise et comme je le disais tout à
l'heure
l'Europe n'ayant pas d'accord
d'adéquation avec la Chine et la Chine
étant extérieure à l'Union européenne il
me semble que le rgpd pour les données
personnelles
des schémas comme celui que nous avons
érigé en France avec new Cloud pour les
données
non personnelles sensibles me semble
être la meilleure manière de protéger
nos concitoyens et de protéger leur
patrimoine numérique
merci beaucoup alors ça m'amène à une
question puisque vous parlez du rgpd
une question qui que je vais développer
à plusieurs reprises parce que c'est
celle sans doute qui nous préoccupe le
plus
vous l'avez bien expliqué le rgpd oblige
les entités les entreprises qui
transmettent des données à des
pays qui ne font pas partie de l'Europe
et qui n'ont pas les mêmes règlements
l'oblige à des accords particuliers et
vous avez dit que ça n'était que ces
accords n'existaient pas avec les
États-Unis bien entendu le Cloud AC et
avec le gouvernement chinois avec sa
politique
interne et d'extra-territorialité or la
CNIL
à bien expliquer dans une
avant d'être obligé de transmettre le
dossier à la DPC irlandaise elle avait
commencé son enquête elle a bien
expliqué dans son enquête que Tik Tok ne
satisfaisait pas
aux obligations du rgbd lorsqu'il n'y a
pas d'accord c'est-à-dire que lorsqu'il
n'y a pas d'accord avec ces pays le rgpd
impose que les chiffres romans soient
fait de l'origine à l'arrivée avec des
méthodes de chiffrement d'une plus ou
moins
élaborée selon le selon le cas or la
CNIL dit expressément dans son rapport
c'est donner ne sont pas chiffrées du
début à l'arrivée et par ailleurs les
méthodes de chiffrement ne sont pas
celles qui sont du niveau souhaité par
les
par l'Union européenne
voilà donc c'est pas une question si
vous voulez et moi cette question
d'ailleurs je la poserai tout à l'heure
en ce qui concerne lactine mais c'est
juste une remarque parce que vous avez
parlé de ce sujet pour vous dire
actuellement Tik Tok ne respecte pas et
c'est pas mon avis c'est la vie de la
CNIL les données du rgpd donc je me
permets juste de vous signaler et je
voudrais passer à ma question à ma
question qui nous est en tout cas qui
moi me préoccupe le plus
Richelieu disait prendre une décision et
ne pas l'appliquer c'est autoriser ce
qu'on veut interdire
le rgpd
puis le DSA ont marqué une évolution
importante dans la régulation de la
jungle des plateformes
le problème est celui de la mise en
oeuvre l'Union européenne a décidé que
la régulation ne serait plus au niveau
des pays de l'UE mais au niveau de
l'Europe
sur le principe moi je n'ai rien contre
je suis européen tout comme vous je le
sais
et par conséquent il faut bien mettre en
commun un certain nombre de sujets
essentiels petit à petit dans la réalité
ce qui se passe c'est qu'on a décidé de
confier un seul régulateur européen le
soin de traiter et de statuer y compris
en matière de sanction pour tous les 27
et c'est la difficile irlandaise
cette situation pose deux problèmes
majeurs le premier c'est que l'Irlande
qui pour des raisons fiscales que tout
le monde connaît et le pays
d'installation de choix des plateformes
et de beaucoup d'entreprises c'est vous
avez cité tout à l'heure l'installation
d'une partie de tiklok en Irlande c'est
le cas aussi de beaucoup de plateformes
pour des raisons évidentes qui doivent
pas être non plus très
sonné très clair très très agréablement
aux oreilles du ministre des Finances
toutes ces plateformes sont là-bas et
beaucoup d'autres entreprises et de ce
point de vue là à mon avis le pays qui
était le moins indiqué pour devenir
celui de la régulation européenne c'est
un choix qui apparaît surprenant et si
vous voulez mon avis ce n'est que mon
avis
vous pourrez me dire que c'est peut-être
une
pétition de principe ou une
en tout cas dangereux
c'est aussi là que Tik Tok souhaite
installer avec la Norvège le projet
Clover donc vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure je pense qu'il faudra qu'on
parle deuxième problème le difficile à
notoirement pas et de loin les moyens de
traiter le sujet à l'échelle de l'Europe
or on a depuis deux ans enlevé à tous
les régulateurs européens si je vais
parler que de la France on a enlevé à
l'arcome et à la CNIL les fonctions de
régulation des fonctions essentielles de
régulation des plateformes
ils avaient un et l'autre commencé des
enquêtes ils ont été comme d'autres
régulateurs européens obligés de cesser
leur enquête dans leur pays et de
transmettre tout à la dépiti le résultat
il est évident deux ans après il y a
toujours pas de réponse alors qu'avec
l'époque la CNIL s'apprêtait à donner
sa décision éventuellement un certain
nombre de sanctions il y a deux ans
après toujours pas de réponse de la part
de la DPC en plus le mécanisme est
terriblement complexe puisque il faut
que la difficile
instruise le dossier à partir de chaque
régulateur européen qui le propose une
décision qu'il envoie la décision à
l'ensemble des régulateurs européens qui
doivent donner leur avis
et que la difficile peut suivre ou ne
pas suivre indemium
je pense autant je pense que le sujet
doit être traité à l'échelle européenne
autant et moi je voudrais vraiment
attirer votre attention là-dessus
[Musique]
nous sommes en train de créer un
mécanisme comme beaucoup d'autres
mécanismes européens et c'est souvent ce
que l'on critique au niveau de l'Europe
qui est en train dans lever tout
efficacité au mécanisme de sanction du
DSA c'est pas vous qui êtes en cause
bien entendu c'est au niveau européen
que ma face est le gouvernement français
il participe
le procès en question les désirs en
question vont prendre des années y
compris quand le DSA sera là et qu'il
faudra l'appliquer et que les
plateformes très majoritairement ne le
plus grand pas complètement elles vont
une fois de plus sentiraient sans
problème puisque
au-delà des deux ans et plus qui sont
déjà qui ont déjà été utilisés par la
DBC plus l'année qui était celle de
l'arcom et de la CNIL
il y aura les recours qu'on connaît et
ça va prendre des années les plateformes
pour le moment sont même pas égratignés
ce qui m'ennuie parce que moi je suis
pour le DSA je suis pour le rgpd je
pense que l'Europe avec le GPD DSA ont
été pionnière et que d'autres pays comme
les États-Unis et d'autres sont en train
de s'inspirer de cela mais dans les
faits les plateformes une fois de plus
vont refaire avec leur milliers de
lobbyistes d'avocats etc vont faire
durer la chose face à une instance de
régulation qui n'a ni les moyens
physiques ni probablement la volonté en
tout cas celle du gouvernement et
néerlandais
même si on peut espérer que la difficile
est dans une certaine mesure
indépendante qui n'ont pas oublié
vraiment une volonté très forte de faire
respecter alors ma question est la
suivante
l'éviction de l'art comme et de la CNIL
du processus de régulation des
plateformes dans notre pays vous
paraît-elle acceptable vous nous avez
dit en introduction que vous seriez
intran
ma question c'est est-ce que vous avez
désormais les moyens d'être
intransigeant
voilà la première question sur ce sujet
qui est un de ceux qui nous préoccupe le
plus pas sur le principe mais sur la
réalité merci monsieur le rapporteur et
moi aussi c'est l'un des sujets qui me
préoccupe en effet le plus je crois que
vous mettez le le doigt sur un point
important qui est un choix qui a été
retenu au moment de la conception du
rgpd
de confier la responsabilité de
l'application de ce règlement à la à la
CNIL du pays où le l'entreprise
concernée dispose de son siège
il appartient donc à la CNIL française
de traiter du cas des entreprises basées
en France la CNIL irlandaise des
entreprises basées en Irlande à la crise
luxembourgeoise de traiter du cas des
entreprises basées au Luxembourg et il
en existe un certain nombre parmi les
géants du numérique
on a pu que constater comme vous le
faites que cela peut donner lieu à une
forme d'hétérogénéité dans l'application
du rgpd et que cela peut donc aussi
créer de la créer ou susciter de la part
des géants du numérique des stratégies
qu'on pourrait qualifier de d'arbitrage
réglementaire
je ne serai pour ma part pas défavorable
à ce que lorsque le moment viendra
peut-être dans quelques années puisque
nous fêtons les 5e anniversaire du rgpd
qu'on puisse renforcer le je dirais
l'harmonisation et la mise en commun des
moyens des des autorités de protection
des données en Europe pour je dirais
faire échec assez tentative d'arbitrage
réglementaire
je reviens maintenant au DSA pour vous
dire que de ce point de vue là les
leçons semblent avoir été tirés puisque
l'application du DSA va éviter cette
écueil et rester entre les mains de la
Commission européenne
il ne restera en tout cas pour les très
grandes plateformes aucun espace pour
l'arbitrage réglementaire en termes de
localisation des centres de décision et
cela me paraît être une très bonne
initiative même si elle doit évidemment
s'accompagner d'une articulation entre
l'action de la de la de la Commission et
celle des autorités qui dans les pays
membres dans les États membres sont au
plus proche du terrain et c'est bien ce
qui est prévu par le règlement sur les
services numériques puisque c'est la
Commission qui est compétente pour les
très grandes plateformes pour les plus
petites plateformes les autorités
nationales restent compétentes en France
c'est l'arcom
qui sera le coordinateur des services
numériques et qui animera ou qui
coordonnera l'action de ses propres
services de ceux de la CNIL et de ceux
de la DGCCRF donc sur le plan des
principes je pense que le DSA nous
permet d'éviter les cueille de
l'hétérogénite et d'application par les
CNIL national du rgpd en revanche vous
avez tout à fait raison d'insister sur
la question des moyens c'est pas parce
qu'on a si l'on peut dire résolu l'une
des problématiques que la problématique
de l'articulation des responsabilités
qu'on a pour autant résolu celle des
moyens
pour la bonne application du Règlement
sur les services numériques ce sont 80 à
120 personnes qui auront été recrutés au
moment où il entrera en vigueur avec une
nouvelle direction placée à la DG
Connect de la Commission européenne
là où il pouvait y avait y avoir
quelqu'un quiétude il y a 9 mois 10 mois
inquiétude que je partageais dont
j'avais fait part à mes interlocuteurs
de la Commission européenne
c'est inquiétudes relayaient également
par des parlementaires européens se sont
très largement atténués au regard des
recrutements qui ont eu lieu
maintenant il faut aussi que les moyens
soient au rendez-vous pour la bonne
application du Règlement sur les
services numériques au niveau national
pour pour tout ce qui ne concerne pas
les très grandes plateformes
et c'est la raison pour laquelle une
direction des plateformes en ligne
a été créé au sein de la recommande en
2019 avec 8 agents actuellement et 10
recrutement en cours
qui viennent s'ajouter à des
je dirais à des affectations au sein de
la Direction des Affaires européennes et
internationales de l'arcom avec deux ETP
consacrés au Règlement sur les services
numériques ainsi que des ETP
sur les fonctions transverses direction
juridique direction des études c'est
donc pour la recommande en tout cas une
douzaine de TP qui sont consacrés à
l'application du règlement sur les
services du mails et c'est un point sur
lequel nous devons être
collectivement vigilant il en va de la
crédibilité de ce règlement le monde
entier regarde avec beaucoup d'intérêt
ou en tout cas avec beaucoup d'attention
euh ce ce l'application de ce règlement
de la même manière que le monde entier
regarder avec beaucoup de d'attention
son adoption il y a donc une question de
crédibilité qui est posée crédibilité de
ce règlement et donc crédibilité de
l'Union européenne dans sa capacité à
imposer un certain nombre de règles dans
la société l'économie numérique
merci monsieur le ministre je poursuis
ma question vous allez dire que je suis
obsédé par ça mais je suis préoccupé
les échos
jeudi dernier sous le titre La justice
européenne donne raison à Google meta et
Tik Tok a publié un article qui dit cela
je vous cite quelques passages les États
membres de l'UE ne peuvent imposer des
obligations qui seraient plus strictes
que celles déjà prévues en Irlande sauf
au cas par cas estime l'avocat général
de la CI de la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne
cette séance tombe bien puisque la
commission d'enquête sur Tik Tok va
rendre ses conclusions à partir au
moment où vous allez discuter avec le
Parlement le projet de loi que vous
portez et qui notamment aura pour de
transférer mais de porter en France les
règlements du DSA et du DM
voilà ce que dit l'article l'un des 27
peut-il imposer aux plateformes des
obligations plus strictes que celles
déjà prévues par le pays où se trouve
leur siège européen l'Irlande dans la
plupart des cas on en a parlé la
question que devait trancher la Cour de
justice de l'Union européenne n'avait
rien de théorie elle était même très
attendue par Google meta et Tic-Toc par
qui l'affaire avait commencé
or je dis l'avocat général de la CGE le
polonemar ciel
spinard leur a donné partiellement
raison il est si magnifique les
plateformes ne peuvent être soumises à
des obligations plus fortes que celles
prévues par le pays de domiciliation en
Europe en l'occurrence l'Irlande je ne
vais pas le dessin
sinon la libre circulation des services
numériques dans l'UE protégés par la
directive e-commerce de 2000 serait
bafoué en clair toutes les mesures
nationales de caractères générales et
abstrait visant une plateforme décrite
en des termes généraux sont exclus en
l'occurrence l'avocat général dit que là
où il y a une directive ou un règlement
européen les États ne pourront pas aller
plus loin
de fait de nombreux pays espéré bien
profiter du digital Marketa et du Djal
service Act les deux règlements
européens qui encadrent les plateformes
pour prendre dans le droit national des
mesures plus strictes ou complémentaires
à celles prévues par le nouveau cadre
européen certes la CGE n'est pas tenue
de suivre les conclusions de l'avocat
général qui éclaire la cour sur les
affaires à traiter pour autant les
géants du web marquent un premier point
pour mémoire l'affaire avait démarré en
Autriche lorsque met à Google et Tik Tok
avait contesté une nouvelle loi adoptée
en 2020 dans le pays pour réguler les
réseaux sociaux les juges du Luxembourg
doivent encore rendre leur avis
vous voyez où je vais en venir
ma question c'est est-ce que l'État
français a été parti à ce procès ou
amicus-curie et je ne sais pas de quelle
façon et quel a été sa position est-ce
que le gouvernement français l'État
français peut-il encore intervenir d'ici
à la décision de la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne et est-ce qu'ils
souhaitent le faire et
en ce qui concerne le projet de loi que
vous que vous prévoyez
est-ce que vous avez prévu de prendre
des mesures plus strictes au sens de cet
article ou complémentaire au nouveau
cadre européen et si oui lesquels et
complémentairement est-ce que vous serez
ouvert des amendements parlementaires
ou la position de l'avocat général si
elle est celle retenue par la Cour de
justice
la position des amendes de certains
amendements
sera-t-elle acceptée par le gouvernement
français ou bien cette décision de la
cgue
empêche-t-elle tout amendement et toute
décision d'ailleurs du gouvernement
français toute proposition du roman
français que se passe-t-il si de tels
amendements sont adoptés au Parlement
merci monsieur le rapporteur alors je
voudrais apporter quelques éléments de
précision sur les propos tenus par
l'avocat général et rapporté par les
échos il manque à mon avis le paragraphe
le plus essentiel je cite un État membre
autre que celui d'origine ne peut
déroger à la libre circulation des
services à la société de l'information
que par des mesures prises au cas par
cas après notification préalable à la
Commission et demande à l'État membre
d'origine de prendre des mesures en
matière de service de la société
d'information ce qui n'est pas le cas de
l'espèce il y a donc une position qui
peut sembler
maximaliste de la part de l'avocat
général mais qui souffrent quelques
exceptions à condition évidemment de
suivre les
procédures prévues à cet effet j'en
viens maintenant au projet de loi qui
vise à sécuriser et réguler l'espace
numérique pour dire que
dans la rédaction du texte nous avons
veillé à ce que les articles ne viennent
pas empiéter sur le compromis trouvé au
niveau européen
pourquoi d'abord parce que nous sommes
comptables de ce compromis après tout
c'est la France qui en a été l'artisan
et qui même si elle n'a pas peut-être
obtenu gain de cause sur toutes les
dispositions du texte à eu le mérite de
faire converger les points de vue pour
faire levier de la puissance du marché
économique européen et instaurer des
règles qui s'imposent dans l'ensemble de
l'Union européenne il va de soi que
le nous avons beaucoup plus je dirais
d'espoir de faire plier les géants du
numérique en parlant en européen que si
nous parlons dans une espèce de
stéréophonie européenne chacun dans
notre coin et deuxièmement parce
qu'effectivement si nous prenions des
mesures qui empiétaient ou qui
détricotait les compromis trouvé au
niveau européen alors ces mesures
seraient fragiles et pourrait être
contester un peu sur les mêmes
fondements que l'affaire en question
devant la juridiction européenne nous
avons cependant pris des mesures de
protection ou de sécurisation dans
l'espace numérique que nous veillerons à
notifier à la Commission européenne
que nous avons par ailleurs sensibiliser
à ces à ces questions et à l'intention
qui qui était la nôtre de le faire de
manière à limiter le
limiter le risque de se de se retrouver
dédié par une juridiction européenne et
on me dit dans l'oreillette que nous
avons d'ores et déjà notifié les mesures
principales du projet de loi qui
pourrait être contestée sur le fondement
cité par par l'avocat général avant même
l'adoption du projet de loi est de
manière à
éviter
le risque juridique qui nous nous
empêchera pas si nous considérons que
l'évolution du texte devait
nécessiter une nouvelle notification de
nouvelles mesures de le faire le plus
rapidement possible pour rester dans les
clous
donc ça va être sportif pour les
parlementaires qui vont vouloir déposer
les amendements
et vous êtes confiant sur la comment
dire la libéralité la marge de manœuvre
qui vous est offerte en l'occurrence
c'est-à-dire que en l'absence d'une
jurisprudence un peu constante et en
dépit du fait que vous avez négocié le
l'accord et que vous avez peut-être une
visibilité sur ce que vous entendiez
voir écrit
est-ce que la marge de manoeuvre est
importante parce que à la lecture de
l'article que nous donne monsieur le
rapporteur on a l'impression que la
marge manœuvre est quasi nulle en dépit
en dépit de la possibilité de notifier
par avance de justifier le caractère
exceptionnel du sujet mais voilà est-ce
que est-ce que est-ce que d'un pays
l'autre il y a une amplitude qui vous
semble suffisante pour permettre à des
gouvernements qui voudraient se montrer
volontariste sur la question des
plateformes de lettres
on a eu un certain nombre de discussions
avec la Commission dans la préparation
de ce projet de loi
je veux préciser que les
l'essentiel des des mesures prévues ou
contenu des articles contenus dans ce
projet de loi
ont vocation à permettre une meilleure
application de la loi je pense à
l'interdiction d'exposition des mineurs
au contenu pornographique
je pense aux retrait ou plutôt non
retrait par les hébergeurs de contenus
pédopornographique il y a là des
interdictions qui sont fixées par la loi
française qui ne sont pas encore tout à
fait appliquées ce que font les
dispositions du texte c'est de préciser
les moyens d'y parvenir ou de rendre
plus effective la loi c'est dans cet
esprit là que nous avons
que nous avons
échangé avec la Commission européenne il
semble il me paraît important en tout
cas pour pouvoir apporter une réponse
définitive à votre question d'attendre
la décision finale de la Cour de justice
de l'Union européenne puisque celle que
dans les échos se faisaient l'écho reste
à ce stade celle de l'avocat général
ça vous donnera un début de
jurisprudence mais qui pour autant sera
pas constante et donc comment dire on
apprend en marchant là sur le sujet
je partage votre avis et
nous serons vigilants dans le
et nous travaillons d'ores et déjà avec
les sénateurs sur le texte qui sera
examiné prochainement pour veiller avec
eux à ce que des dispositions qui se
viendraient empiéter sur les compromis
trouvé au niveau européen ne viennent
pas fragiliser l'édifice
merci beaucoup donc je rebondis sur ce
que vous venez de dire on va passer à un
autre sujet qui est celui du contrôle
d'âge
le contrôle d'âge sur Tik Tok comme
d'ailleurs sur toutes les plateformes et
sur les sites pornographiques
est une vaste blague je pense qu'on sera
d'accord là-dessus il y a pas de
contrôle d'âge aujourd'hui
nulle part
les déclarations des dirigeants Tik Tok
explique qu'ils sont très attentifs à ce
que des mineurs de 13 ans n'est pas
accès à l'application
c'est déclarations sont risibles en même
temps ils publient une statistique sur
le nombre de leurs visiteurs par
leurs utilisateurs par classe d'âge et
on s'aperçoit qu'il y a des enfants
de moins de 13 ans bien évidemment
et d'ailleurs tout le monde connaît des
enfants de 8 ans qui sont sur Tik Tok
c'est même l'appli favori des moines des
moins de 15 ans
ce qui cause aussi le problème de la
récente loi sur
la majorité informatique
donc tous les sapés mais peut-être je me
trompe que dans deux mois quand le DSA
va s'appliquer vous avez dit le 25 août
Tik Tok ne sera pas en mesure elle n'est
pas la seule mais notre commission dans
lequel c'est sur TikTok et c'est surtout
celle qui a le plus de public très jeune
de mettre en place un contrôle d'âge
sérieux parce que si pour moi le seul
contrôle d'âge je crois qu'on en a déjà
discuté ensemble le seul contrôle d'âge
sérieux c'est celui qui recouvre un
tiers de confiance et un certain nombre
de mécanismes assez élaborés s'il devait
être mis en place dans deux mois ça
serait parce qu'il serait déjà en
travaux en préparation etc mais
peut-être je peux me tromper
je pense que ça va être très très
difficile
donc je me réfère à ce que je disais
précédemment est-ce que quel sera la
position du gouvernement français si ce
contrôle d'âge n'est pas différent de ce
qu'il est aujourd'hui sans parler même
de la reconnaissance faciale qui est
parfois évoqué et qui posera évidemment
d'autres d'autres problèmes majeurs
est-ce que en fonction des décisions de
la Cour de justice si elles suivent la
vocale générale ou en fonction
du DSA et notamment le gouvernement
français a les moyens juridiques de
faire respecter en France les
recommandations du DSA sur le contrôle
d'âge ou est-ce qu'en cas de conflit ou
est-ce qu'en cas des accords il faudra
attendre 5 ans que le difficile prenne
une décision
et que les recours soient apeurés
donc pour être plus précis est-ce que
vous avez un programme principal pour
imposer ce contrôle d'âge et d'ailleurs
mais c'est accessoire
nous demande pas des réponses parce que
c'est pas le sujet de notre commission
mais accessoirement
bien qu'il y ait pas mal de soft formes
sur Tik Tok que compte faire la France
quant aux principaux sites
pornographiques c'est la justice ne
condamnait pas ici dans la décision
qu'elle doit rendre prochainement
merci monsieur le rapporteur et je crois
qu'effectivement il y a une un véritable
sujet et le terme est faible
lorsqu'on s'aperçoit que 9
ou 90% des jeunes de 11 à 12 ans sont
sur TikTok alors que le réseau social
a fixé une limite d'âge basse pour
l'accès à son service de 13 ans
c'est à dire que Tik Tok ne fait pas
lui-même respecter ses propres
conditions générales d'utilisation
le Règlement sur les services numériques
ne prévoit pas explicitement de
vérification d'âge il cite la
vérification d'âge comme l'une des
mesures que les plateformes peuvent
prendre pour limiter les risques
systémiques qu'elles font peser sur le
bien-être et la santé de leurs
utilisateurs et en particulier la santé
des enfants
en revanche une proposition de loi
d'origine enfin de l'Assemblée nationale
a été adoptée dans les deux chambres qui
prévoit que un contrôle d'âge sérieux
doit être réalisé
et que pour les mineurs de 15 ans le
recueil du consentement parental doit
être fait pour les réseaux sociaux
autrement dit
modulo les notifications à la Commission
européenne qui qui vont être faites dans
les prochains jours si elles n'ont pas
déjà été qui ont été faites également
nous disposons d'un cadre pour imposer
aux réseaux sociaux de faire cette
vérification d'âge de la même manière
quand juillet 2020 le Parlement a adopté
un cadre pour imposer aussi diffusant
des contenus pornographiques de vérifier
sérieusement l'âge de leurs utilisateurs
la question qui reste à régler à
trancher c'est celle des moyens pour
parvenir à cette vérification d'âge
je commencerai par l'exposition contenue
pornographique puisque c'est un sujet
sur lequel nous travaillons depuis un
certain nombre de mois et
qui fait l'objet vous l'avez rappelé
d'une procédure judiciaire donc devant
le tribunal judiciaire de Paris
dont le verdict est attendu le 7 juillet
prochain
aujourd'hui des systèmes de vérification
d'âge existent et notamment pour les
mineurs de 18 ans ils ne sont pas
parfaits mais ils existent et la CNIL
comme l'arkom considère qu'ils sont des
pisalées et que les les plateformes
n'ont qu'à ou en tout cas les sites
diffusant des contenus pornographiques
n'ont qu'à se saisir de ces outils pour
limiter enfin l'exposition des mineurs
au contenu pornographique je rappelle
qu'il y a deux millions d'enfants qui
sont exposés chaque mois au contenu
pornographique dans notre pays
c'est système
tolérer à court terme en tout cas par la
CNIL et par larcome ce sont les systèmes
fondés sur des cartes de paiement ou des
systèmes fondés sur l'estimation de
l'âge à partir d'une photo du visage ce
sont des solutions qui ne sont ni
totalement fiables
ni totalement sûr
et sur lesquels nous devons à partir
desquels nous devons imaginer des
solutions qui soient plus fiables et
plus sûr
nous avons encouragé des entreprises
françaises à se lancer dans le
développement de solutions plus fiables
et plus sûres qui repose sur une
application installée sur le téléphone
de l'utilisateur qui va solliciter de la
part de prestataires
externes une preuve anonyme de majorité
preuve anonyme de majorité qui sera
sollicité de la part du site réservé aux
adultes auxquels l'utilisateur veut
accéder sans que le site réserve aux
adultes n'est à connaître l'identité de
la personne en question
ces solutions que nous avons encouragé
certains industriels français à
développer
sont
expérimentés sur le plan technique
actuellement
elle
produiront je l'espère
tout leurs effets et elles pourront être
utilisées ensuite pour d'autres usages
et y compris même si ça n'est pas aussi
simple pour la vérification d'âge à
l'entrée sur les réseaux sociaux puisque
les limites d'âge à faire respecter sont
plus basses 13 ans 15 ans et nécessite
donc des solutions un peu plus éprouvées
encore mais je n'ai aucun doute sur le
fait que nous y parviendrons
nous avons donc pour résumer un cadre
juridique pour le pour imposer cette
vérification d'âge reste maintenant et
nous nous y employons à ce que les
solutions techniques puissent être
développées le plus rapidement possible
solution qui garantissent à la fois la
fiabilité de l'assimation d'âge la
sécurité des données personnelles et
puis pour certains services
le la protection de la vie privée de
l'anonymat
merci beaucoup ça va être un peu juste
pour le 25 août
est-ce que à partir du 25 août je ne
connais pas le calendrier je suppose
qu'il y a un calendrier pour se mettre
en conformité normalement c'est le 25
août mais je suppose qu'on va pouvoir
continuer à discuter alors une nouvelle
fois
le règlement sur les services numériques
en lui-même n'impose pas explicitement
la vérification d'âge il est il évoque
la vérification d'âge de même que les
interfaces adaptées à l'âge de ludividu
utilisateur comme l'une des
l'un des moyens de parvenir à l'objectif
de réduction du risque systémique que la
plateforme fait peser comme une mesure
corrective du risque systémique que la
plateforme fait peser
[Musique]
il est donc possible que des plateformes
comme Tik Tok pour
satisfaire aux exigences du DSA plutôt
que de vérifier sérieusement l'âge même
si
j'ai la conviction que les plateformes y
viendront toutes une fois que certaines
des solutions auront été éprouvées meta
expérimente par exemple des solutions
d'estimation de l'âge par photographie
du visage ce n'est pas encore déployé
partout mais cette expérience dans
certains pays je pense qu'elles y
viendront mais au 25 août elle pourront
elles pourront évoquer d'autres mesures
qu'elles prennent pour protéger les
enfants
en revanche le régulateur la Commission
européenne sa nouvelle équipe pourra
effectivement
demander des comptes et exiger que les
solutions avancées répondent bien à
l'objectif de protection des enfants et
donc nous ce que nous faisons c'est que
nous prenons de manière explicite en
droit national une une mesure qui qui
fait appliquer ce qui existait enfin ce
qui était déjà en quelque sorte entre
les lignes du rgpd c'est à dire la
majorité numérique nul ne peut
s'inscrire quand il a moins de 15 ans
sur un service numérique sans le
consentement explicite de ses parents
donc ce que fait cette proposition de
loi c'est de dire que
désormais puisque
c'est une règle qu'on s'est donnée avec
le rgpd encore faut-il la mettre en
œuvre concrètement recueillir l'âge de
l'utilisateur recueillir le consentement
des parents
si vous permettez ce qu'on si on
comprend bien ce que vous voulez dire
c'est que à partir du moment où certains
pays et non des moindres
introduiraient dans leur droit national
c'est obligation qui même si elle n'est
pas fondée sur le texte dont vous allez
travailler la transposition entre
guillemets mais qu'on le passe par un
autre biais notamment sur la question
majorité numérique les plateformes ne
vous ne voyez pas comme les plateformes
pourraient trouver un intérêt ne
serait-ce que pratique et de gestion
quotidienne à avoir des systèmes
d'autorisation différents d'un pays
l'autre c'est-à-dire qu'à partir du
moment où un pays imposerait la
vérification d'âge ils vont y venir quoi
c'est ça votre
même presque par simplicité de gestion
derrière oui et aussi parce que
il n'y a pas d'harmonisation au niveau
mondial
de la régulation de l'espace numérique
et s'il y a un sujet sur lequel le
consensus peut se former et à mon sens
se formera c'est sur celui de la
protection de l'enfance en ligne et sur
la protection de l'enfance en ligne la
mère des batailles c'est la vérification
de l'âge et je pense que la pression va
s'accroître nous avons des échanges avec
d'autres pays membres de l'Union
européenne mais à l'extérieur de l'Union
européenne également qui cherche eux
aussi les moyens d'imposer cette cette
vérification d'agent en revanche je veux
simplement préciser que
il a été considéré que la parce que vous
me posez cette question tout à l'heure
que la proposition de loi qui est qui va
prochainement après la commission
mixparitaire de venir loi
sur la majorité numérique n'empiétez pas
à notre avis sur le règlement sur les
services numériques au sens où le
Règlement sur les services numériques
régit le contenu des applications mais
ne régit pas les conditions
d'inscription sur les services et qu'il
était donc
possible
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement a soutenu cette proposition
de loi il était donc possible de
légiférer en droit français
vous répondez quasiment ma question dans
la foulée qui était de savoir au moment
de la négociation du texte au niveau
européen et puisque vous nous expliquez
que finalement le contrôle d'âge n'est
pas inscrit dans ce texte en tant que
tel mais qu'il est vu comme une
préconisation pour faire baisser le
risque systémique
j'imagine un que la France a malgré
toute défendu l'idée de la mesure d'âge
au niveau européen
je sais pas ou alors c'était pas dans le
sujet
la France au moment de la négociation
sur le règlement sur les services
numériques alors je vais je vais essayer
de préciser ma réponse je l'ai pas j'ai
pas la réponse toute prête mais ce que
la France
a fait en parallèle du Règlement sur les
services numériques c'est l'adoption du
contrôle parental et ça et sa
généralisation qui ne revient pas
exactement à la vérification d'âge à
l'inscription aux réseaux sociaux mais
qui revient au contrôle de l'âge au
niveau des des équipements
je
si vous me le permettez je reviendrai
dans quelques instants pour vous
confirmer si oui ou non la France a
défendu cette et donc la question
subsidiaire et j'en termine c'était de
savoir que si nous avons défendu cette
position là et que ça n'est pas dans le
texte européen j'aurais aimé savoir
quels sont les pays en Europe qui ont
été chef de file de ce refus
d'inscription si tenté que ça a été un
sujet je serais curieux de savoir si
sans faire de brosser l'intention si
l'Irlande ou d'autres ont défendu l'idée
que c'était pas utile d'avoir une mesure
d'âge généralisée voilà et de savoir
d'où part les uns et les autres
mais je vous le demande quelques
instants pour pouvoir répondre à votre
question
merci beaucoup monsieur le mini je vais
vous poser une dernière question parce
que il faut qu'on vous libère vous avez
déjà passé pas mal de temps avec nous et
vous avez d'autres choses à faire
je voudrais vous parler de du projet
parce que là aussi c'est l'Arlésienne
c'est l'air les yeux aux États-Unis avec
Texas le projet Texas qui dure depuis 5
ans et sur lequel il y a toujours aucune
aucune réalisation
5 ans aux États-Unis c'est quand même
beaucoup
avec Oracle qui est qui est pressenti
qui est d'une société qui a tous les
moyens nécessaires et tout et puis rien
avance aucune décision moi j'ai peur que
ça se passe un peu comme ça pour Clover
et que ça met autant de temps si non
plus
et c'est l'habitude comme c'est
l'habitude de des plateformes de TikTok
comme les autres de faire des
engagements de prendre des engagements
de faire des projets et puis on discute
on discute et à la fin à la fin ils ne
sont pas grand chose pour le moment sur
Clover non seulement il n'est pas sorti
grand chose mais on a même pas d'annonce
sinon que il compte consacré à un
virgule deux milliards d'euros par an au
projet Clover bon c'est pour faire des
systèmes de serveurs sophistiqués etc
c'est une c'est une orientation qui
paraît assez normale et qui n'a rien
d'extraordinaire
mais
depuis les deux ans que Clover est
abordé et je pense que Monsieur Andersen
a dû en discuter avec vous oui on avait
dit tout à l'heure bon on a comme sur
les autres sujets beaucoup de promesses
mais on a même pas ce qui pourrait
paraître le minimum c'est le choix de
l'opérateur
ça a l'air secret
est-ce qu'il s'agira d'un opérateur
français ou à minima européen
je pose pas la question par hasard parce
que il est probable d'ailleurs ils l'ont
indiqué que des logiciels américains
traitement de données soient continuer à
être appliquée comme ils le sont
aujourd'hui et c'est à dire que nous
serions dans un cadre particulier qui
est celui de la soumission au Cloud
actes américains et qui voudrait à
nouveau les mêmes problèmes qu'ils ont
posé aujourd'hui par le par le rgpd donc
je voulais vous demander si vous avez
quelques précisions supplémentaires à
celles que nous avons nous avons pas
beaucoup sur le projet Clover est-ce que
vous en pensez
en gros
merci monsieur le rapporteur peut-être
pour apporter quelques éléments de
réponse
à monsieur le Président sur la question
de la position de la France pour dans
les discussions
et la négociation du Règlement sur les
services numériques c'est une
proposition qui a été faite par la
France mais qui ne figurait pas au rang
des lignes dures lors de la discussion
c'est un sujet comme je le disais tout à
l'heure que j'évoque avec un certain
nombre de mes homologues
et en particulier les les Pays-Bas qui
s'intéressent de très près à ces
questions de protection de l'enfance en
ligne et par ailleurs la DG Connect à la
Commission européenne travaille avec le
pérenne
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure sur ces
sujets sur lesquels le pérennes a
développé une certaine expertise
ensuite j'en viens à la question de
monsieur le rapporteur sur le calendrier
de mise en œuvre du projet Clover
les responsables de l'entreprise ont
bien exprimé leur engagement à réaliser
le projet toutefois concernant
un calendrier précis de mise en oeuvre
la situation est encore en cours de
développement et à dire vrai le premier
calendrier qui nous avait été évoqué me
paraissait bien trop étendu car je
répète comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
qu'aujourd'hui Tik Tok n'est pas en
conformité avec le rgpd et que si l'on
peut dire les
nous nous tolérons en quelque sorte
cette mise en oeuvre par le projet
Clover de la conformité au rgpd mais je
crois que il ne faut pas jouer trop
longtemps avec les nerfs des Européens
s'agissant de la protection de leur
donner personnelle je le disais c'est
pas dans mon le respect du rgpd n'est
pas une faveur que nous demandons c'est
une exigence que nous posons un centre
de données est déjà opérationnelle à
Dublin et je comprends qu'un autre étant
construction en Norvège géré par la
société Green Lantern un délai de 15
mois a été annoncé pour l'achèvement de
ses projets c'est bien long même si
même si ce ne sont pas des délais qui
sont inhabituels pour ce type de projet
industriel bien qu'un engagement clair
ait été exprimé pour sa réalisation le
calendrier précis de sa mise en oeuvre
reste à préciser tes négociations sont
actuellement en cours concernant le
tiers de confiance une composante clé de
ce projet comme vous l'avez rappelé
je
souhaite que ce projet intervienne le
plus rapidement possible et je veillerai
personnellement et régulièrement à ce
que les engagements pris par TikTok soit
scruptueusement respecté je souhaite
comme vous que le prestataire soit
européen
il y a
les fournisseurs de d'informatique en
nuage américain qui sont exposés au
Cloud actes il y a des prestataires
désormais en cours de certification par
l'ansy
le certificats secs new cloud qui
garantissent une forme d'immunité au
Cloud
[Musique]
je trouve que c'est extrêmement
rassurant monsieur le ministre parce que
quand on est l'audition l'autre jour de
Monsieur Garandeau on avait presque
l'impression que 20 millions de Français
et si possible parmi les plus jeunes
étaient devenus en fait par la grâce de
TikTok des amateurs du cinéma d'arrêt
d'essai parce que Tik Tok c'était le
renouveau des années forts c'était une
de nouveau contenu et les créateurs de
demain j'ai pas entendu ça dans votre
bouche aujourd'hui et finalement
peut-être que dans la conduite des
auditions et notamment les
principalement par monsieur le
rapporteur on n'a pas été tout à fait
dupe de cet aspect là des choses
c'est-à-dire qu'on a bien à faire à des
plateformes et en l'occurrence on
s'occupe de Tik Tok dont on n'est pas
comment dire qui en tout cas ne nous
épates pas fondamentalement par les
contenus proposés et toutes les mesures
de régulation ou de ou de cadrage qui
serait mise en oeuvre sont quand même
très très loin de porter atteinte à ces
questions éventuellement de créativité
donc c'est plutôt plutôt rassurant
et la deuxième remarque que je
souhaitais faire elle porte vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure
s'agissant des fonctionnaires et on n'a
pas eu tout à fait la réponse sur le
pourquoi du comment de pourquoi Netflix
mais pourquoi pas Google pourquoi pas
d'autres mais je ne vous relance pas sur
cette question je voudrais simplement
faire remarquer que du fait du covid et
des nouvelles habitudes qui ont été
prises il y a quand même pas mal de gens
qui s'interrogent sur le fait de savoir
pourquoi l'État ne diffuse pas plus je
dis pas ne propose pas parce qu'ils
existent mais ne diffusent pas plus et
pourquoi n'est pas plus spontanément
diffusé l'usage des outils qui vraiment
sont internes à l'administration je
pense aux questions de Visio je pense
aux questions de de messagerie qui sont
sécurisées comme tel parce que si nous
étions un peu plus acculturer que nous
avions une hygiène numérique un peu plus
forte sur ces aspects là et bien
peut-être que ça pourrait faire
justement faire tâche d'huile dans les
milieux économiques ou dans des milieux
plus sensibles quand on sait aujourd'hui
que dans l'éducation nationale parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de directives contraire
en un certain nombre de d'enseignants
qui utilisent par exemple Instagram pour
faire passer les devoirs ou faire
travailler les élèves on peut se poser
la question de la difficulté de votre
tâche quand par ailleurs il y a ces
usages là qui sont développés par
l'administration elle-même voilà c'était
simplement de de remarques que je
voulais saisir l'opportunité pour les
pour les faire si les collègues présents
n'ont pas d'autres questions et si
monsieur le rapporteur fait le tour du
sujet monsieur le ministre je vous
laisse conclure si tenter que vous ayez
une un mot à nous dire et autrement
voilà je vous laisse le mot de la fin en
tout cas
merci monsieur le Président sur
le point que vous soulevez je crois
qu'effectivement l'État doit être
exemplaire je crois que nous avons
amorcé un virage avec la doctrine du
cloud de confiance à la fois en édictant
des règles qui sont claires en soutenant
l'émergence grâce à France 2030 d'offres
de solutions logicielles de suites
collaborative souveraine on a évoqué
tout à l'heure old vide mais il existe
pour un certain nombre de ses services
de des couches hautes de l'info nuagique
donc de l'hébergement en ligne un
certain nombre de prestataires qui sont
pour l'essentiel en train de solliciter
la certification sec num Cloud et puis
nous disposons pour les couches basses
de l'hébergement des champions français
je pense à un certain nombre d'entre eux
qui
coopèrent entre eux à la fois avec les
couches basses et couche haute pour
développer des solutions qui à mon avis
dans quelques mois seront susceptibles
de répondre aux besoins des
administrations faudra-t-il encore
évidemment faire évoluer un petit peu
les habitudes c'est à dire que il faudra
pour se conformer à la doctrine du cloud
au centre
prendre en main des outils qu'on avait
peut-être pas tout à fait l'habitude
d'utiliser mais qui pour autant peuvent
délivrer la même qualité de service et
puis enfin c'est vrai ce qui m'a
particulièrement frappé chez Tik Tok
c'est que la promesse initiale je disais
dans mon propos introductif était
effectivement de construire un
algorithme d'exploration qui permettent
la découverte du monde la découverte des
contenus culturels etc mais de ce point
de vue là la promesse n'est pas tenue on
a bien face à nous un algorithme qui est
un algorithme d'enfermement ceci étant
dit cela n'exonère pas TikTok de
respecter la propriété intellectuelle
les droits d'auteur je crois qu'il y a
encore un peu de travail dans ce sens là
et je suis certain que la commission
d'enquête sera faire des recommandations
pour orienter l'action qui doit être la
nôtre merci en tout cas pour les travaux
qui ont été les vôtres et
[Musique]
au plaisir si je puis dire de lire les
conclusions de votre rapport